with the exception of humans and
possibly that one mole rat it's weird to
think of living things as naked this is
particularly true for microbes who often
seem to be made up of well arranged
squish that requires very little in the
way of ornamentation but we have met a
few members of the macrocosmos who have
figured out how to brighten up their
exterior like the silica fresh jewels
made by diatoms that harden their walls
these structures don't satisfy any kind
of internal diatomaceous vanity but
rather offer protection against things
like UV light and then there are the
amoebas the classic amoeba of popular
imagination is generally considered
scientifically speaking naked their
pseudopodia or false feet transport
they're shifting unadorned bodies
throughout the macrocosmos but as we
have discussed before amoebas are a
polyphyletic group we've grouped
different species together because in
the early days of microscopy they seemed
to resemble each other in a way that
suggested a close relationship but with
molecular tools that reveal the hidden
history encoded in their DNA we have
learned that these relationships are
actually much more distant and that the
term amoeba does not define a single
taxonomic group rather it's a
descriptive term encompassing organisms
that exhibit that distinct crawling
amoeboid movement using its pseudopodia
so saying something is an amoeba is more
like saying something as a flier than
saying it is a bird birds are all
related to each other but a flyer might
be a bird might be a bat might be a
ladybug might be a pterodactyl but this
distinction remains important as we
venture into the lives of test
eight amoebas the more modest
compatriots of the naked amoeba much
like amoebas as a whole the grouping of
testate amoeba is a polyphyletic one
lumping together amoebas who encase
themselves in a shell called the test
the test acts as protection from changes
in the environment as well as from
potential predators but it also contains
a hole or aperture from which the
amoebas pseudopodia can come out and do
what it needs to do different tested
amoebas assemble their shells out of
different materials in some cases the
test is autogenic meaning that the
amoeba produces its own building
material for example the shell of this
arcella here is made out of a single
layer of what is called proteinaceous
alveoli which is comprised of a keratin
like protein this shell is shaped like a
dome with a central cavity that holds
the aperture our Sela produces this
shell during binary fission readying it
for the newly produced daughter cell
before starting division it will collect
the protein building blocks inside its
cytoplasm and as division starts the
arcella will extend its cytoplasm
through the aperture to create a bud
where those building blocks then get
gathered and assembled and converted
first into the right materials and then
into the right shape and when the new
test is done forming the cell itself
begins to divide the our cell is shell
starts out colorless but with time they
may become colored with accumulating
iron and manganese other autogenic tests
may be made up of different materials
like silica or calcium carbonate but
there are also amoebas who gather the
materials to make their shells from
their environment making what are called
Zeno genic tests
one example of this are the diffusion
amoeba whose shells are composed of
various materials including quartz or
even diatom fresh jewels that are stuck
together using the organisms own special
glue their tests also called agglutinate
shells come in a variety of shapes
elongated lobed
horned there is an elaborate set of
descriptors used to specify this
beautiful morphology different species
take on while some of their structures
may appear at first glance to be random
the aperture in particular often shows a
much more orderly arrangement some
species have a tooth like pattern lining
the aperture while others have a more
rounded structure at first glance de
fallujah might not seem particularly
dexterous given the hardened shell they
choose to live in they survive largely
on bacteria and algae anyway so
nimbleness may not be their primary
concern but they have still managed
feats of agility that have astounded
their observers in one case a scientist
documented a diffusion at aking rotifer
the amoeba stretching six long
pseudopods through its aperture to trap
its prey by the feet how it managed to
detect and quickly snare its prey
remains a mystery but of course amoebas
are always teaching us just how
deceiving appearances can be a lesson
that is constantly reinforced as they
demonstrate the limitation of trying to
establish evolutionary relationships
between these organisms just by looking
at their morphology amoebas are a
polyphyletic group of blobby organisms
tested amoebas are a polyphyletic group
of blobby organisms with a shell and in
2012 scientists established that de flu
Jia would share this common
characteristic of how they make their
shells and thus seem pretty closely
related are in fact a polyphyletic group
of blobby organisms with a particular
kind of shell
even within this group distinguishing
between species has been a major
challenge because it relies so heavily
on our observations of shell size and
shape slight changes and shell structure
might make one species appear to be
different but we see so little of the
organism itself
and thus we can't readily rely on other
cellular features to distinguish them
it's only with genetic techniques that
we can begin to unravel more about the
creatures inside the shell and
unraveling these things is important not
just to our understanding of amoeba but
also how we study the world around us
tested amoeba are abundant and
distributed in waters well around the
world and they're quite sensitive to
conditions like moisture or pH perhaps
most importantly their shells are well
preserved a rarity and the microbial
world and the accumulation and
distribution of their shells allows
scientists to study not just current
tests at amoeba populations but also
ancient ones whose remains can reveal
what their environments may have looked
like even with the vagaries of
establishing different species and
evolutionary relationships tested
amoebas have been extremely useful paleo
bio indicators but learning more about
their diversity and taxonomy will
sharpen the kind of inferences
scientists working in that field can
make providing more insight into both
microbial evolution and ecological
change for all their influence and long
storied impact on our earth
microorganisms have a pretty ephemeral
vibe their life cycles are often short
and when they die they usually leave
behind very little while the legacy of
ancient microbes encompasses every level
of life the only traces of their
individual identities are encoded in DNA
but sometimes as with the test date
amoeba they leave behind a little
something extra the shells that protect
the amoeba while alive and remain
evidence of their existence long after
they are dead
perhaps no one mourns the amoeba but we
do study them and in doing so they teach
us many things including just how
complicated such a seemingly simple
organism can be thank you for coming on
this journey with us as we explore the
unseen world that surrounds us a journey
that we could not beyond if it were not
for the people listed on the screen
right now these are our patreon patrons
and you can be one of them with your
name listed here among those who make
this kind of content possible all you
have to do is go to patreon.com/scishow
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes James check out Jam and
germs on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby
you